when I started working for my dad at 22
years old I told him I will spend zero
minutes on our competition he thought
that was the craziest [__] he ever heard
he was obsessed with what every liquor
store in New Jersey did and what they
got did they get a better deal on this
vodka why didn't like he just spent all
his energy on everyone else I said Dad
the only people I'm going to pay
attention to is first our employees
second our customers and way down here
number 29 I'll have a sense of what the
competition's doing because you never
want to be delusional and audacious but
when I tell you that very few seconds
will be spent on them because what they
do has no impact because nothing and no
one on that list is stopping you from
doing what you need to do attention is
the number one
asset